[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to well we
got a little bit of a tradition going on
here every single time a DC film comes
out I always had to review it because
let's face it
DC films give you hope the hope that one
day they'll actually make a good DC film
not anymore
to talk about you're inevitably crappy
movie that was the old DC this DC brings
back what we loved about our classic
heroes okay look Jesse the cowgirl I've
heard this stick before oh this is the
DeeZee film that's gonna change
everything this one's actually good that
the trailer looks so great well you know
what I'm not falling for it
only Phil McGee excited for this year's
the emoji movie what what damn laughs
r-truth come with me and I'll show you
that I'm the hero that the DC movies
have been waiting for sure about this
did the creator of Wonder Woman also
create the lie detector I don't know did
he he did he did yeah
the more you know okay but give me a sec
I gotta do the intro here first what am
I supposed to do I don't know
get us hyped up with a totally
inappropriate yet amazingly awesome
electric guitar theme you may be awesome
but you're not Wonder Woman playing
electric guitar awesome
[Music]
Wonder Woman has been a popular icon
since the 40s being one of DCs top three
most marketable brands yet while their
top two most popular brands Batman and
Superman have gotten several movies and
cinematic suicide notes in the past
Wonder Woman has been strangely absent
she had a hit TV series in the 1970s hey
you may be cool but you're not Wonder
Woman skating with appropriate helmet
and knee pads cool and made a few
appearances in animation but a cinematic
movie never happened
hell they would make a film out of Steel
with Shaq before giving her her own
movie well with cinematic universes
being all the rage and DC trying to
catch up with Marvel's success they
debuted the character in Batman V
Superman and she was said by many to be
one of the few saving graces of the film
but could her kick-ass cameo translate
well enough to make a big hit with
audiences and critics well let's take a
look and find out this is what is this
but this movie is not nearly feminist
enough and we need to talk about it man
no we have to talk about half this movie
isn't good it'll end all female
superhero movies yeah no no no forget it
I'm not grabbing any of your complaint
bait but there is so much to get
needlessly upset but other people can
talk about the political social equal
not equal whatever issues I just want to
judge this movie as a movie so piss off
but as a feminist I'm deeply insulted
pretty good shut up by being offended
for you we need to talk about thanks
Wonder Woman you fight for my right to
wear satin tights
Dimplex or trust not everybody knows
yeah I don't think you could pull that
off just start the review right
[Music]
we start off with our main character
Diana as a child on the island up
thermos that and she's really used by a
society of Amazon women who enjoyed
their bright colorful landscapes and the
beautiful color yeah yeah and what's
that the Sun what DC movie have you been
watching hey you get rid of that for me
all right out of the way out of the way
you're gonna make some changes here
there we go much better much better now
that's how you do a DC film will you get
you out of here we are trying to do
something different and better oh I'm
sorry we're not Marvel you can do
something different and better and not
be like Marvel's I didn't know that oh
it's all shit Rafa Diana's mother the
queen of the Amazons explains the
history of where they came from long ago
the god Zeus told the God Ares not to
try and overthrow him Ares agreed but he
was totes lying and Zeus was like bitch
I am Zeus and he told his arrogant ass
counts to make sure a psychotic monster
like that never took over again Zeus
created the Amazons and then he
destroyed the Electoral College and I
get to be an Amazon when I grow up no
because I sculpted you from clay and
brought you to life really
no but it's easier than telling you
where babies really come from but I want
to be a warrior
she's right sister she's a frustrated
princess longing for more and going
against her parents wishes if we stayed
this route will be a Disney movie well
only if she saves a handsome man from
the sea let me train her no you must
okay wow that was fast
it's a two-and-a-half-hour movie yo we
gotta move it along okay good point so
Diana is trained as an Amazon
her mother is afraid you'll find out the
truth about who she is the nice thing is
this is a DC origin story where not
everything is told in the beginning they
save some of it as a mystery a mystery
that's answered in one movie rather than
the secret don't ask about that I really
think that I should two-and-a-half-hour
movie people take bathroom breaks okay
okay
but Diana sees a plane crash into the
sea and say it's the pilot inside you're
a man yes I am World War one pilot Steve
Trevor
really your World War 1 pilot Steve
Trevor I just I thought you'd be more
Chris package look there's now a lot of
black people in this movie if we played
it for real the only role I'd have is
the black Amazon it's a good thing I
saved you from that fake CGI effect oh
don't worry there's much more of those
in this movie just look at this slow-mo
bullet from the enemy soldier follow me
[Music]
truth and Steve to find out all about
the great war could this be the work of
our sworn enemy Ares I can't prove that
it's not mother we have to stop him in
his evil ways
no mankind is much too violent and
dangerous we're better off serving our
crazy gods who are so bloodthirsty we
literally have one named the God of War
Steve is there anything you're not
telling us they'll kill you if you don't
confess truth be told I'm okay with that
I always fantasized I would die in an
island full of nothing but Amazon women
I just never thought it would actually
happen though I could do without that
[Music]
film that Diana doesn't listen though
and she steals the sword of ultimate
power known as the god killer and saves
Steve from his prison to get him back to
the war but she stopped by her mother
Diana what are you doing I'm off mother
I'm gonna defeat Ares fighting the Great
War and
I'm the hero that everyone will soon
call wonderful no one will call you that
what no one will call you that like
nobody you mean they never works that in
not even as a joke nope oh my god we're
gonna be fan for stick they never said
their name either we're gonna be for
stick oh my god you're not going to be
fun for stick nothing can be as bad as
fantastic just breathe I still think
it's a bad idea for you to go I am the
queen of the Amazons and I say you are
not an Amazon then technically you're
not my queen and I don't have to do what
you say mmm true okay bye
Oh wink that twice
[Applause]
[Music]
you
hey Doug Walker here for Walters top 5
show we are celebrating the 10-year
anniversary of nostalgia critic and you
get to help just go the link below make
sure you have a Google account which if
you have a YouTube account you have a
Google account and vote for your
favorite episode of nostalgia critic the
top 5 episodes that get the most votes
will be on the show
voting ends on June 26 at 11:59 p.m. so
let us know what your favorites are
[Music]
[Applause]
this leads us to the film's villain
general ludendorf and his partner dr.
Poisson who's kind of like an alternate
version of Michael Crawford's Phantom of
the Opera
half the faces cover the acting is
over-the-top and the voice is clearly
that of a woman general send in the next
subject these two are trying to create a
gas that can kill someone even if he
wears a gas mask Steve is aware of this
and tries to give the information to war
councilmember Sir Patrick
Tammy Trevor who is this young woman
Diana Prince is her name really because
it sounded like she said princess of
thermos key did you think I would just
miss that part
it's her maiden name really yes says a
thermos key is her maiden name it's
foreign and she says it after her
married name it's just how they do
things where she's from you racist
well it's 1918 so yes and of course we
gotta put up with the sexual prejudice
that you would expect mr. Trevor you
know a woman it's not allowed in this
room of men and it goes on and I'm being
super preachy never mind all that you
want to go stop back to poison and take
her with you go right ahead have fun oh
that was refreshingly quick well you
know the fish-out-of-water county's
gonna go on and on tear those big
dresses yes but I did not like them okay
let's go almost like the movie obviously
knows we obviously know these obvious -
no tricks I mean don't get me wrong with
the time period and set up both sexism
and the fish-out-of-water element have
to be addressed but it's not hammered
into the point of annoyance it's good
fronted dealt with and then they move on
to the cool stuff most viewers want to
see in fact a good chunk of the time is
spent with her getting to know the men
she's fighting with making a strong bond
to connect with the people she's sworn
to protect dammit you're not supposed to
actually talk with the people you save
you're supposed to talk about the people
you save to show how awesome you are you
think we're doing it yeah check this out
symbolism Jesus I am Jesus you're
welcome yeah that's always done the way
that's how it's done
so what future superheroes are they
gonna be
those aren't future superheroes they're
just they're people no no no no no no
let me bats Blaine you see every single
side care during a superhero movie has
to have a superhero spin-off they gotta
be superheroes in a future movie yeah
yeah bare minimum this connection to the
soldiers and the people's suffering
builds up perfectly in the truly
inspiring scene where Diana breaks
orders and walks on to what is now
literally no man's life
[Music]
Jenner they're launching a strange move
kind of her lousing attack I am Diana
defender of all that is full
come on then don't hide in the trenches
like a pussy get out there rally around
her as her god-killer does exactly that
destroying a chapel serving as the
control base for a town of tortured
people she makes her way to a party to
kill general ludendorf and dr. poison
but steve says it'll result in tons of
people die
thus he stops her resulting in tons of
people die the very town she saved is
now up and gas and smoke what a woman
says screw harsh reality she wants her
comic book vol shit back so she finds
general ludendorf at his base and tries
again to finish him off Fateh are you
shortening your subscription to life
yeah I made these God pills now you can
totally fight huh thank you yeah
even a god can stop me now
the God with a really sharp object
but has par for most movies nowadays
there has to be a surprise villain Aries
wait what yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
hello this is a joke for the review
right that's not really the God of War
right no it's totally in the movie that
is the God of War you see he didn't
cause people to start the war but he did
plant ideas for them to do it well you
know it's awesome killing people your
idea not mine killing people would be
awesome and that's my idea not Ares
he creates war through humanity's hunger
for violence and he serves as their muse
for creativity have you ever thought of
a body crushing gas for peaceful
purposes I'll create Nickelback no don't
do that
even I'm not that evil just get to the
gas I mean if it pops in your head I
don't air okay so here's the thing as
much as I'm sick of the villain being a
surprise at the end it does kind of
match this hero's journey
Wonder Woman thinks it's a simple good
versus evil tale but discovers things
are not so black and white
hell even this particular war was not so
black and white so it creates more of a
challenge for ethical loyalty but here's
the problem
Ares the God of War and entities so
powerful it took on Zeus is a pasty old
British guy hey I am very intimidating I
once asked to pass the salt and I didn't
say please
you are as intimidating as the monopoly
guy Hey we used a crappy effects to
photoshop my head on a muscular body see
I am totally worth nightmares and as you
know I had a bad dream last week they
play cricket with no kneepads oh-ho
enough of this professor plum I own saw
myself as a caramel master I am gonna
kill you with my disintegrating sword
and brother when it disintegrates it
disintegrates
[Music]
well what do you know and now I will
show you my real which I'm sure you'll
be more comfortable with
all right now this is what I'm talking
about this is the Aries from the comic
this is the God of War this is Hilaire
still an old British fuck oh come on
just because it's this face under all
this armor doesn't mean I'm any less
cool look I'm going to throw things out
I know you see that was very
intimidating fire lightning all
commanded by a Monty Python care come on
don't get any better when Wonder Woman
realizes Steve is flying a plane filled
with the poison gas into the air to blow
it up sacrificing himself well it could
be worse it could be killed by a
dickless doomsday wow that pirate died
faster than your 2011 TV series
yes Diana now you realize the sword was
never the gone killer you are the God
and now I will kill you with every DC
villains ultimate weapon is that written
dialogue mankind is inherently evil it
is in their nature to destroy themselves
this guy gets it
so long-winded so needlessly details
watching a bedtime story Christopher
Nolan's challenge yeah oh Christ
oh yeah okay okay you gonna miss us
now Diana kill the one responsible
symbolically representing how you've
given up on humanity even though you've
already killed like a bajillion of us
already
no I will not kill her because I have
faith in love but I will kill you for
that same faith in love okay none of
that makes sense you let her care you
kill me and somehow you were to love
into all that you are banca oh yes what
are we have a two-hour 10-minute mark
yeah I should probably die so then it
destroys the FOP of war and vows to keep
the fight for love alive by laying low
in France 400 years okay I'm not gonna
lie I totally don't get most of this
ending but for only the last few minutes
not to add up instead the majority of
the film that's a DC miracle
[Music]
and that was Wonder Woman is it as good
as everybody says it is yeah and for a
reason actually a little different than
most superhero films nowadays see here's
the thing what superhero started they
were gods icons the people you looked up
to for being better than you they did
the right thing just because it was the
right thing
but after a while it was becoming old
they started to seem way too perfect
so superheroes want the more personal
route making it more about the
individual portraying flawed rebels like
their readers as opposed to orderly role
models like their parents and it was
great they got more angsty more dark
more human than ever before but
something interesting happened when
Wonder Woman walked onto that
battlefield in the middle of a film it
wasn't Batman walking to avenge his
parents it wasn't spider-man walking to
be responsible for his powers it was
just a hero who wanted to help people
there was no tragic backstory no art no
terrible event that made her compelled
to do it she did it because that's who
she is that's what she knows that's what
she connects with and it's not her
powers that make her that way it's her
character it's still a hero's journey
but this hero makes it about the people
she saves she always wants to help them
always wants to do what's right
and for no other reason except she just
wants to this is a type of hero we
haven't seen for a while and honestly
for good reason we needed the personal
touch the brooding the angst and we
still do it led to some of the most
popular greatest superheroes of all time
but sometimes we forget we need this
type of hero too not Superman fighting
Zod while ignoring the debris falling on
people not Batman trying to kill another
hero for hypocritical reasons but a
we're walking on to a battlefield
because she feels it's the most she can
do we haven't seen this kind of here on
the big screen since the Richard Donner
Superman I think was starting to be seen
as too corny and not dark enough that's
understandable but that's the genius of
setting it in World War one it's the
perfect paradox it was real but far back
enough for distance it was filled with
extremes but subtleties as well the
worst of humanity the best of humanity
an environment where a comic-book hero
can save the day but still witness the
harsh outcomes of reality creating both
light and dark perfectly this this is
what DC is at its best
if Marvel is humans becoming gods DC is
gods becoming human and this is that
done right this reminded me of what's
wonderful about DC and why it's
characters are still timeless when done
correctly it blends myth with reality
the ordinary with the extraordinary
mortal with immortal it's the closest we
have to occur in Greek mythology it's
honest its powerful it lasts forever
this is the movie that made me remember
why I love DC in the first place I'm the
Nostalgia Critic and
yeah what's this it's your cake and you
can eat it too
[Music]
actually oh I didn't know that yeah
right here I mean the magic hand or I
gave it to me it's it's hand cake I will
literally dice okay you um mind if you
play us out while I eat hand cake
[Applause]
you may be awesome but you're not eating
hand came next to Wonder Woman playing
electric guitar awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out on this week we are doing
public color public color engages
at-risk students in their education and
empowers them to plan and prepare for
college and a career through a continuum
of youth development in their
educational programs that starts with
teachers teaching them how to paint
vibrant colors in their schools they're
creating a new sense of school community
and safety their model starts with
struggling underserved inner-city
schools but that's not where it stops
once they finish a school they extend to
the community to local police precincts
and neglected neighborhood facilities
since 1996 public color students and
corporate volunteers had transformed
over 400 schools community facilities
and playgrounds from dreary dark and
dangerous to safe bright and vibrant
educational and community centers if you
check out their site and their YouTube
channel you can see all the great work
that they've done as well as projects
you can either donate to or volunteer
with take a click and bring a whole new
world of color into the world
you